so he is a naughty bass what a pain
what do I do with this well last time
when we were dealing with Exponential's
we had to do a few um we had to do a few
back flips with like rules with
Exponential's and that kind of thing the
index laws and what-have-you mercifully
this is a little bit easier right you've
got a problem you don't know how to do
it you don't know how to solve it so
what's this mathematical technique this
strategy that we use over and over again
when you encounter a problem that you
don't know how to do what do we try
what are we search for what are you
thinking today yeah I want to change a
problem I don't know how to solve to
make it look like one I do know how to
solve and then I can just off I go right
and in this case the thing you're going
to use is the change of Base Lord you
remember that okay now you haven't done
logs for a little while you haven't done
logs for a little while so maybe you do
not remember what goes over here do you
have your reference sheet there you have
your reference right there if you turn
to the second page I mean the second
page which actually has stuff on it not
the page after the title page if you
have a look at the the second page the
second to unit page before it actually
turns around to the back you will seeing
a change of base law it's written there
right this is the one and one only log
law that you will find on the entire
reference shape because it's sort of the
weirdest it's not as easy to get out of
the Exponential's so I want you to look
at that closely I want you to look at it
closely
and I want you to look at what we've got
here I want to write something here in
place of log base two of X that I can
actually differentiate so it's gonna
have bass in it right what would you
write it's going to be a fraction
there's going to be a log of some kind
on the top and a log of some kind on the
bottom what's it going to have you take
it what's on the top
okay so log base e of X just because
when I normally say log X I would imply
a log a pick they say but because I've
got another base flying around I will
specify just so you know what on earth
I'm talking about what about the bottom
II do have we used the law correctly
just check make sure it looks right yeah
so you can see the new base it appears
twice and the way I remember like which
one goes to which because you can use
the reference sheet but to be honest the
two unit component of the reference
sheet it's not really designed for you
you guys are extension students and if
there is a kind of backup but you're
costing time every time you go there
once you get a little more familiar with
this in jog your memory you shouldn't
need to go the reference sheet to find
this I remember the two is lower and the
X is higher so the two is lower in the
exercise not that hard to remember okay
now have a look at this the top do I
know how to differentiate that I do
right that's the law I just derived okay
I know how to do with that what at the
bottom what is this thing it's just a
constant right is a constant two is a
constant I don't need to worry about it
in fact if I wanted to make it really
clear I would just take it out the front
right because it's just a constant
multiply it by the derivative of log X
is that okay I actually haven't done any
differentiation yet which is why that
derivative guy is still there and now
I'm pretty much there this is 1 over X
this guy over here yeah so 1 over log 2
times 1 over X I guess a nice simple way
to write it would be 1 over X log 2 ok
so if you compare this to what happens
when you differentiate an exponential
with an unnatural base there's kind of
this symmetry there right which
shouldn't be that surprising since it's
the same object looked at from a
different perspective okay now the last
one to have a think about to let you go
on these questions is chain rule now
this is a bit tricky I want you to see
if if you can start from this guy I'm
not even going to leave much space for
it cuz I reckon you guys manage if you
started from this log of any function
right so there's an inside function just
like you're used to dealing with with
chain rule okay how do you how could you
come up with like what substitutions
could you put in to actually find the
derivative for this and get a rule out
of it if that's a bit too abstract for
you put something real in there put
something like say log of I don't know
2x minus 1 what substitution would you
introduce how would you change
than the derivatives to get an answer
for this see what you can come up with
I'll give you a two or three-minute head
start and then I'll show you how it
looks on the board if you're completely
at a brick wall okay here's what we'll
do we'll start on the bottom because
it's always easier I sort of threw you
in the deep end it's always easier to
start with something concrete and then
generalize from there but if you're a
super brain who's like I can I can go
straight for the abstract one then good
for you okay if I had this bottom one
down here right if what I was
differentiating was this it might be a
little easier to deal with if I actually
had a name for this function right all
this is is differentiate blah whatever
comes on after that right so here's what
I'll do I'm just going to call this guy
why okay now remember chain rule for
integration and for differentiation it's
really just like a shortcut named
version of substitution right you're
like I let me substitute something for
this the inside function and that makes
it easier to deal with just like we did
before so I'm going to introduce a
substitution we always use you what
would you like me to put the inside
function 2x minus 1 will do in most of
the cases that you have to deal with the
substitution you have to make is either
given to you or blindingly obvious for
those brave souls who do extension 2
like you get something that you're like
what am I even supposed to substitute
into this and actually half of the
problem is working out what you're
supposed to substitute thankfully for us
it's just like whatever you pretty much
see in those brackets okay now once
you've got that you need to of course
find the derivative of this guy which
mercifully is simple in this case it's
just two done while I've got a
derivative of D on DX I also need the
other derivative that I'm going to chain
together to give me the derivative I
want so I'm going to do the substitution
over here and now I can find dy on do
you these are the two derivatives that
will fit together to make the derivative
I want what is the derivative of log u
we just derived this it's one on you
that that's the variable of choice in
this case because I did my substitution
okay I'm ready to go I can put these two
guys together dy
on DX will be first derivative
multiplied by second derivative not that
the automat is that much in this case
one on u times two of course you was
just something I introduced to make the
question render the question easier to
deal with but now that I've done the
differentiation part I can just put you
back to what we started with right so
this looks like put that on the
numerator where it belongs to on 2x
minus one okay so if I were to try and
generalize this and say well what
happens if it's not 2x minus 1 what
happens if it's some other thing right
some general function f of X okay well
watch what happens as we flow through
right I'm not going to substitute in U
equals that I'll substitute in u equals
whatever that function happens to be 2x
minus 1
you know x squared minus 4 whatever
you've got in there so that will become
f of X okay now being in this case I
don't actually know what f of X is then
when I do this differentiation I don't
know that it's 2 or it's 14 or e to the
X so I'm just going to call it f dash
right now you guys know I don't I don't
love I'm not in love with - notation
because it's ambiguous sometimes
especially when you've got powers flying
around but in this case when you use
function notation it's reasonably
unambiguous that that's what we're
talking about
okay so f ef - what about this line is
this line going to be any different now
that I'm considering a general function
rather than this specific one like the
whole point of choosing you to be that
function is so that I can get back to a
simple thing just log of U so this line
will be the same which means this line
will be the same this is where things
become different right that two over
there is only two because of this guy
right but in this case it's going to be
well that's going to be f dash and this
U is just F okay so what I'm getting my
final line is that dy on DX would be
this guy
so you learned chain rule when you had
to deal with polynomials stuff raised to
a power you learnt chain rule when you
had to deal with I rubbed it off already
when you have to deal with Exponential's
now you've got like a new version of
chain rule for logs chain rule sort of
changes clothes every time it deals with
a different family of functions okay so
this guy here if you wanted to have a
big box around something it's the
derivative of log of any function
do you like okay you're just going to
get take that inside thing it'll be f
dash on F that's a nice succinct way
this data okay
[Applause]